il se retient mais il est furieux robert
lafrenière était le grand patron de
l'upac il est maintenant désigné comme
l'un des suspects d'une enquête
criminelle du bureau des enquêtes
indépendantes sur les fuites
d'informations dans les médias c'est
complètement faux le fait de mentionner
dans une théorie que j'ai orchestré
données ou peu importe le verbe des
fuites pour m'améliorer au niveau de mon
renouvellement pour avoir un corps de
police c'est complètement faux cette
théorie c'est le coeur du projet serment
du berry qui dure depuis trois ans et
demi adam de nuit je vais vous le dire
j'ai jamais envoyé de documents ou remis
des documents acquis quand après avoir
rencontré 130 témoin le berry allègue
que robert lafrenière serait la source
de 6 fuite et que ses proches
collaborateurs seraient impliqués dans
treize fuites mais les documents sont
imprécis sur qui aurait laissé fuir quoi
d'avoir imaginé steve c'est fort alors
vous êtes qu'ils ont imaginé des et
s'allume ces allégations étaient
jusqu'ici inconnu du grand public mais
elles ont été déterminants dans
l'acquittement de nathalie normandeau et
marc yvan côté parce que l' enquête pour
identifier les auteurs des fuites
entraîné des délais déraisonnables
alors c'est mon sens main mais on
part avec la théorie cajarc estrecho
puis nous y ont trouvé des choses autour
où ils ont mis les choses au taux
championnat aujourd'hui dans une vision
snare
précisé masque on nous reproche seront
nos poches
je pense exactement la même histoire se
répète mal inverse tout un retournement
de situation
le juge perreault adhère à la théorie du
bo y ai conclu que l' enquête qui a mené
à l'arrestation de guy ouellette en 2017
ont été faussement orienté par robert
lafrenière et ses adjoints et que le
projet a de l'upac était carrément bidon
convaincu ce tant qu'athlète à bonn
absolument encore aujourd'hui même si
tout le monde l'a construit encore
aujourd'hui robert lafrenière dit que
les enquêteurs du projet serment n'ont
toujours pas demandé sa version des
faits le pays confirme que l'enquêté
toujours en cours et espère soumettre un
dossier au directeur des poursuites
criminelles et pénales en décembre ici
marie maude denis radio canada montréal